are you tired of amusement parks with
hidden liberal agendas are you sick of
woke progressives ruining your family's
vacation are you white well come on down
to republican disney you don't have to
be white that's just a that was a
demographic survey question for
marketing purposes i don't see color are
you tired of amusement parks full of
bigotry are you sick of uneducated rubes
ruining your family's vacation do you
crave fun and guilt well come on down to
democratic disney we're the only
amusement park in america exclusively
dedicated to diversity equity inclusion
real science true history and other
morally unambiguous things that we can't
debate anymore because of nazis
republican disney has all the wholesome
family fun you could want without any of
the dangerous propaganda the radical
left uses to indoctrinate children no
crt no grooming no drugs or sex or math
just a place where you can be proud of
who you are and where you come from but
by which i mean america i don't i do not
mean that in a racial way here at
democratic disney we believe in fighting
the man on behalf of the little guy so
join the resistance and team up with the
white house the senate the house of
representatives and all of hollywood and
academia to say we're the little guy
fighting the system you can meet your
favorite republican disney princesses
like cinderella a classic american
success story who worked hard didn't
complain and after she met her husband
stopped wearing shoes or ariel from the
little mermaid a real nice looking young
lady who doesn't talk or maybe even snow
white who dammit no okay stop no i know
what you're gonna say it's not about
that princesses are an outdated vestige
of the patriarchy our equitable and
gender inclusive disney people acts hold
no land or titles and come in all shapes
colors and healthy sizes visit the hall
of good american presidents like trump
reagan second reagan before he raised
taxes second reagan jr and the one and
only abraham lincoln who freed the
slaves and was a republican yeah yeah
think about that he's on our team splash
mountain is now brokeback mountain the
enchanted tiki room is now the
culturally sensitive pacific islanders
desi and other people 16 1619 project
and main street usa is now main street
copenhagen because while i love america
i sure don't like it we took on a ton of
new debt when we removed disney's
self-governing status but we got a lot
of cash when we let coal companies strip
mine big thunder mountain yes ticket
prices have increased this year that's
because of
russia take a ride on the fiscal
responsibility coaster which skyrockets
into the air and plunges into the ground
depending on which party's in power get
ready for a fight at the haunted mansion
it's a regular mansion but it's scary
because billionaires are an abomination
at republican disney you don't have to
worry about some transgender using the
wrong restroom we have guys in goofy
outfits check everybody's genitals
before and after they leave a restroom
or elevator visit yesterdayland where
you can unearth decade-old tweets from
disney characters change the meaning of
the word they used then execute them
outside in an alley visit yesterdayland
in the 50s when things were perfect or
check out tomorrowland it's dead
finances the entire park the hall of u.s
supreme court justices is closed due to
leaks but come back next year because
we're planning a massive expansion no
snowflakes on these frozen rides and
kids love the tea party teacups don't
worry we check everybody's genitals
before and now do you want to explore
the universe well shame on you you
should visit don't go to space mountain
where you can yell at an animatronic
entrepreneur for trying to build a
spaceship with his own money employing
thousands of people they should be
fixing world hunger spaces for taxpayer
money the old west shootout is no longer
confined to a single stage in fact all
visitors are required to show proof of
citizenship and open carry throughout
the park nothing smaller than a nine
millimeter people no exceptions masks
are mandatory vaccinations are required
and ticket prices are tiered to reflect
your personal privilege every admission
includes a three-hour diversity training
and struggle session so that you can
better understand your inherent
privilege and latent racism also these
sessions are self-directed because it's
not our job to educate you you have to
do the work feeling hungry get a taste
of food and culture from all over the
world with cuisine from america england
germany
maybe france and that'll do it the whole
world you'll have a blast in little san
francisco can you avoid stepping in poop
can you get a building rezoned no you
cannot visit little iraq and be greeted
as liberators can you find the wmds
doesn't matter fireworks do you like
fireworks well every evening antifa
lights fire to our security guards take
a stroll take a stroll through our
historic military industrial complex
smugglers run where you sneak banned
books past republicans smugglers run
where you sneak menthol cigarettes past
democrats smugglers run where you sneak
pregnant women across state lines
smugglers run where you hunt pregnant
women crossing state lines we've
replaced all of the offensive robots and
pirates of the caribbean with new robots
built by forced uyghur labor in china
our dark unmonitored tunnel of love is
extremely popular with firebrand
conservative politicians
like
too popular we're a sex positive resort
bang wherever you want very european
every day at noon the park grinds to a
halt thanks to the trucker convoy parade
every day at noon we have a protest
rally where liberal arts majors dress up
like ninjas and break
we had a protest once we do not talk
about it several times each day we
forcibly relocate people waiting in line
to other lines they hadn't planned on it
takes longer and you don't wind up where
you want it but
equity several times a day we will
inspect your genitals any woman found to
be pregnant is not allowed on any ride
if you are pregnant you should not go on
this ride
unless you want to go on this ride it's
a small world after all which is why we
need tariffs or free trade it's which is
it now
what's today it's a small world after
all so let's divide it equally by force
if necessary democratic disney because
the best dreams happen when you're woke
republican disney the happiest race on
earth place damn it
please god damn it i keep doing that